hey guys what's up my name is eage and
today i'm here at buzzfeed to read some
thirst tweets and it finally begins
let me just take a moment to prepare for
this real quick oh here we go with all
the respect sir i would like to
volunteer to be the next chair you sit
on i respect this one if there's if
there's like spice i think this one's
like uh like a medium like a good like a
good spice that you would put in your
jacket for sure no i'm not exactly sure
what that means like am i just am i
sitting on your legs jay are you an
elevator because i'll go up and down on
you
jay you're so hot every time i see you
i'm screaming but the s is silent ah
it's a good one very creative eight out
of ten for sure why part j when you can
ride j
do you guys even know what that means
may i respectfully lick your face i pay
a lot of money for my skincare products
so like i would probably advise not i
mean if that's something that you're
into
i've had a lot of things happen to me at
the front of stages our concerts people
people grab everywhere man i don't think
i've had a concert where i've been in
the front where i haven't had a hand on
airmen jay park get your ass over here
so i can cuddle you and make you feel
soft and cozy and special challenge
failed wait that's like a cute one
that's like a nice one isn't it okay
respect that that's that was that was
very comfortable to listen to jay park
please strangle me with your bare hands
uh i'm not into that but i think my
friend corpses so you can probably hit
him up for that jay's vein is so sexy
was that you at the er yesterday sexy
nostrils king i love you
i'm getting so confused sexy nostrils
i'm trying to understand this let me let
me just dissect this for a second my
nostrils you talk about the flaring
right yeah i'm probably not gonna miss
this one notice me then i'll break up
with my boyfriend please please don't do
that i've i'm already i'm on cancel
cooldown right now like i want to cancel
again petition for mr park jae-hyung aka
each to cut me into tangyopsar cuts
using his jawline and slurp me using his
chopsticks okay thank you and goodnight
that's my last one
okay oh my god jay those tattoos you got
me horny ass thank you
oh jay can step all over me with muddy
boots and i will say thanks daddy you're
welcome son do you need a doormat i can
be your doormat i am an excellent
doormat i will be the best damn doormat
you've ever seen you can stop all over
me and i will thank you please let me be
your doormat i would love nothing more
than to be your doormat i'm officially
in my doormat era for you uh once again
i'm gonna refer this one to my friends
i'm not so much into stepping on
doormats but my friend ray probably i've
seen her tweet that a lot so that would
probably where this tweet should be
going please step on me and spit all
over me while singing car crash i know
who this is from and that was pretty
tame for you good job probably the
church this sunday jay can you be my
boyfriend for one minute i think it's
gonna last a little longer than that
jay are you mixed because you look 50
fine percent mine jack noticed me
noticed and uh wholesome tweet
my request blue hair j do be looking so
fine though let's let's forget that ever
happened
jay you must be a traffic ticket because
you've got fine written all over you
that's a compliment right thank you
i appreciate that so like the one one
thing i don't understand about these
tweets is like you see me right like you
see my two pimples right here and i this
is kind of how i present myself so like
where do you guys get thirsty for me
from i'm confusion good luck reading
these tweets my dear daddy hot ass mr
jae hyung park aka the sexiest 68th most
handsome man in the world thank you
finally someone mentions it uh for those
of you who don't know i was actually
nominated 60th most hazmat in the world
so
nothing too crazy but just just putting
it out there jay as you said you have a
beautiful voice care to moan my name i
could try wow that was
a lot more wholesome than i thought it'd
be because the ones that were popping up
on my feet we're talking about guzzling
a lot of so i appreciate you guys for uh
probably not including those and me not
knowing how to react to them at all
thank you buzzfeed for having me check
out car crash i'll see you guys again
hopefully someday
[Music]
you